Veamos si podemos dividir 30.24 ÷ 0.42. Te invito
a que pauses el video y trates de resolverlo por
tu cuenta antes de que lo resolvamos juntos. Hay
un par de formas de pensar en esto. Podríamos
escribirlo simplemente como 30.24 dividido entre
0.42 , ¿y qué hacemos ahora? Lo importante es
darte cuenta de que cuando estás resolviendo
un problema de división como éste obtendrás
la misma respuesta siempre que multipliques o
divididas ambos números por lo mismo. Y para
entender eso reescribiré esta división como 30.24
/ 0.42. Podemos escribirlo como una fracción,
y sabemos que cuando tenemos una fracción
como ésta el valor de la fracción no
cambia si multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por la misma cantidad, entonces
¿por qué podríamos multiplicar este denominador
para convertirlo en un número entero? Bueno,
podemos multiplicarlo por 10 y luego por otro
10, es decir, que podemos multiplicarlo por 100,
así que hagámoslo. Si multiplicamos el denominador
por 100, para no cambiar el valor de la fracción
también necesitamos multiplicar el numerador
por 100. En realidad estamos multiplicando
por 100 / 100, que es un entero, así que no
estamos cambiando el valor de esta fracción,
de esta división. Entonces esto va a ser 30.24
x 100, movemos el punto decimal dos lugares a
la derecha y nos queda 3,024, el decimal ahora
estaría ahí, y 0.42 x 100, nuevamente movemos el
decimal uno, dos lugares a la derecha, ahora
es 42. Entonces esto va a ser exactamente
lo mismo que 3,024 ÷ 42. Aquí también podemos
mover el decimal dos posiciones a la derecha,
y si lo hacemos entonces tenemos que mover
estos dos hacia la derecha también. Y este
es ahora la posición del punto decimal, nos
queda 3,024 ÷ 42. Ya sabemos cómo abordar eso,
pero hagámoslo paso a paso. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 42
en 3? Bueno, ninguna en absoluto, así que podemos
usar 30. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 42 en 30? Bueno,
tampoco cabe en 30, así que podemos pasar a 302.
¿Cuántas veces cabe 42 en 302? Y siempre es todo
un arte dividir entre un número de dos o varios
dígitos, así que pensemos un poco en ello. Esto es
aproximadamente 40, esto es aproximadamente 300,
entonces ¿cuántas veces cabe 40 en 300 o cuántas
veces cabe 4 en 30? Bueno parece que cabe unas
siete veces, así que voy a probar con un 7 a ver
si funciona: 7 x 2 es 14, 7 x 4 es 28 + 1 es 29,
y ahora puedo restar, reagrupo un poco aquí,
tomo 100 de estos 300 que se convierte en 200,
teníamos 0 decenas, pero ahora tenemos 10
decenas, y voy a necesitar una de esas decenas,
así que eso va a quedar como 9 decenas, y la
voy a pasar para acá. Entonces esto va a ser 12,
12 - 4 es 8, 9 - 9 es 0, 2 - 2 es 0. Entonces lo
que me sobró es menor a 42, por lo que sé que 7
es el número correcto. Quiero que quepa tantas
veces como sea posible en 302 sin pasarme. Ahora
bajemos el siguiente dígito, vamos a bajar este
4 de aquí. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 42 en 84? Podemos
ver que cabe dos veces, 2 x 2 es 4, 2 x 4 es 8,
lo restamos y no hay residuo. Entonces 3,024 ÷
42 es lo mismo que 30.24 ÷ 0.42, y será igual a
72, esto es igual a 72. Y con esto terminamos.